good morning
this is jessica
she's 15.
are you tired still
jessica needs someone awake with her day
and night
she has a chromosomal abnormality
uh what about this one and is now
receiving palliative care
we've been working really well with the
hospice at getting her pain managed and
this week's a good week
jessica's mom alison gave up work to
look after her daughter at home
the family has state funding for
full-time nurses and carers so what are
you going to do in school today but
there simply isn't enough staff
there are frequent absences and alison
has to do 24-hour care and although in
front of jessica she's all smiles
can i have a kiss
thank you privately it's breaking her
i'm so tired
yeah i think
feeling worthless and so tired it's not
good
i just don't think that's thought about
enough i think
it's oh we haven't got any cover okay
but i'm absolutely desperate i'm
exhausted i don't feel i can do this
well i'm really sorry but you've got to
there is no
so
however you say i don't think i can do
this
it doesn't matter you've got to and
that's the end of it and as parents we
do don't when we keep going and we will
just keep going because that's
for our children and we'd be the last to
be thought of
come on let's be going
today there is a carer to be with
jessica at school
for alison it'll be rare respite
i know i'm jess's mom and parental
responsibility and all of that
but it's it it's above
parental responsibility what we're what
we're doing at home we are full-on
nurses and you know i am
i'd say that i'm very lucky in a
situation where i can't stay at home but
that at the moment is becoming
increasingly difficult
price is a rising of things and i really
need to be able to go out to work
financially
but if you actually can't do that it's
difficult what do you do
i have no idea what what we do
let's go you got your bag of pictures
with you families say they feel
forgotten caught between local
authorities nhs groups and care agencies
who simply don't have enough staff
it would be too simplistic to say that
this current shortage of care staff is
just because of the covert 19 outbreak
yes of course the problem has been
exacerbated by the pandemic but in
reality disabled children services and
social care has been underfunded for
many years by billions of pounds and no
family or organization that we've spoken
to believe that the problem is going to
improve anytime soon
there are more than 100 000 families
across the uk with very sick or disabled
children at home
research shed exclusively with sky news
by charity world child found that eight
out of ten families are not getting the
care they are entitled to
people have
a little baby and you're tired because
they're not sleeping it's like that but
all the time
in huddersfield jill evans has stayed
awake 35 nights in a row to look after
her son noah and she's preparing to do
the same again tonight
35 nights i mean
not even somebody working on a ward
would do more than four
heaven forbid
if i missed something with noah and it
was on my watch you know if his
tracheostomy tube blocks
and i miss that because i've fallen
asleep
that that's life threatening to know
it's just
a nightmare
on so many levels something's going to
give well yeah and
my care of looking after noah can't be
it
and
um
it's frustrating because the thing
that's going to give in the ends
probably me
i don't know
noah has a rare lung disease and needs
someone with him all the time
because of care shortages he's been
missing up to three days a week of
school
charities warn children like noah who
with support could thrive are slipping
behind i realize that there isn't just
money for everything
and something has to have priority
but honestly if there was people that
were in government that weren't making
decisions on um how they were going to
spend that money if they did like a day
in the life and they came and did 24
hours here they would be saying right we
need to at least get some emergency
situations in place it's just
absolutely
not acceptable it's an accident waiting
to happen
we contacted the department of health
and social care who said we owe carers a
debt of gratitude and that more than 462
million pounds is going into recruitment
for more staff
no but this is what you're going to sing
tonight you must be learning it for a
concert or something but that money is
to cover the entire social care sector
and families looking after children
behind closed doors say they are the
last to be thought of
catherine of autopsy sky news